who is the Atlanta housewife that you
hinted about having beef with on
Instagram it's not candy
oh
everybody's wanting to know about the
beef about the beef yeah fans have
questions as Tamar Braxton reignites her
Feud with candy Burris I believe in
making amazing television you know with
without making it all about drama but
the internet never forgets like Tamar's
Instagram story back in December when
she revealed she has beef with someone
from The Real Housewives of Atlanta and
their husband alleging she was
threatened by the unnamed couple what's
your question for Tamar no surprise here
the cryptic post coming back to haunt
her who is the Atlanta housewife that
you hinted about having beef with on
Instagram saying her and her husband
threatened you
people think
it was Eva no it was not I know who it
is
it was not and it really did happen I'm
not lying like I'm not looking for
attention or drama anything like that
right that really did happen it was not
cute no uh
was she a full housewife she's a full
house
it does get a little spicy it's not
candy
oh
lamb I thought you and Candy men did
everything after big brother I thought
so too I had no idea wow okay I'll tell
you the story later yeah only Andy gets
the backstory for now but Tamar
continues the conversation on social
media tweeting the fact is Candy and
Todd wanted to fight me and over on the
gram she calls the couple's Behavior
abusive and disrespectful everybody's
wanting to know about the beef about the
beef meanwhile candy addressed the drama
on Amazon live the other thing I would
say right now is
you know simply that
that's not true my husband never said
nothing to her he did not threaten her
or none of that she and I did have words
so how do we get here let's rewind it
hurts more when we have arguments this
comes after candy claimed that a
Housewives producer tried to make a
biopic about her band escape the reality
star took issue with the unauthorized
and alleged production and this was
followed by Tamar who's performed with
escape on tour defending the producer
and I honestly truly forgot about it
Tamar claims she was confronted
backstage at one of their concerts I see
candy
like
give her a hug
you know whatever she just look at me
and she's like you I'm like what what
happened oh and remember this quote from
the clubhouse I thought you and Candy
men did everything after big brother I
thought so too I had no idea we got to
watch you and Candy reconnect bury the
hatchet sometimes you have to go back
and revisit the path and kind of hash it
out so you can get a clear understanding
as to oh I'm so sorry I didn't know that
hurt you and apologize and move on I
tell you the story later
[Music]
thank you